The jogan
Experience what do you think the UFO
phenomenon
is yeah so I think first of all that
there are a lot of different varieties
of it but when we look at like we were
looking at the Francis of a CCE and the
kind of historical things and the
abductions and things like that um I
think
that that it's been around for a long
time and that these are are things that
are in communication with us so I used
what I do in my book both the books that
I wrote about this is I go I I talk to
people who I think represent thousands
of people so each person in the book
represents thousands if not more maybe
many thousands of people who have had
experiences and the ways in which they
interpret them so all of the people seem
to have had experiences where now what
they want to do is they actually want to
work for justice in different ways like
Jose the veteran in my book he's working
with young people and helping them deal
with being addicted to social media and
things like that and helping them get
through life which is really hard right
now and and that's what he's doing um
and then you look at Dr Whitley right so
she's she's working in the space force
she's trying to you know help people
deal with the fact that they're seeing
things that you know that could down
ples and things like that and she's
helping people talk talk about that
she's helping people um each person in
you know is somehow doing what I'm I'm
suggesting that I think is an out this
kind of structural Injustice that we see
so I think that this is a
transformational thing without the drugs
is what's going on like some kind of
massive experience that people are
having and now it's getting out and
people are being able to talk to each
other through Reddit communities and you
know different types of social media so
it is um it's it's we did see you know
religions when they begin they become
viral at one point we've never seen it
in an age where we have digital
technology but this is what we're seeing
now what do you think the physical
objects are well okay so this is
something that's very interesting we
just looked at the Shroud of Turin I
believe that there are these I would
call them and this is just my own
non-scientific term um interdimensional
objects they're objects that have
characteristics of our Dimension and
it's some other
dimension so some other dimension has
the capability or some from some other
dimension has the capability of
transporting a physical object into our
realm or even imprinting onto a physical
object yeah how so well I don't know I
mean I think that's do mean by what does
that mean imprinting onto so with the
shroud of Trin we see the imprint of you
know the image and if it's real yeah
yeah if it's real um but it's it's an
anomalous object so we do have from Gary
Nolan engineered objects that we don't
know how they're engineered but they
definitely look like they're you know
it's it's
off-planet um I would call the kinds of
things that we see in the historical
record interdimensional types of things
now how I don't know Joe okay so I just
don't know but I do think that
scientists in the government know that
these things exist and they would like
to figure it out and so part of
disclosure the disclosure movement is
outsourcing this and trying to get as
many people as possible to to help in
figuring it
out what do you think when they use the
term
donations what do you think the purpose
of that is if there is a of an object
that is purposely released into our you
know like I'm sure you're aware of cargo
Colts right so with cargo colts for
people that don't know there's been some
islands uh during World War I and World
War II where planes landed there and
they left and these people to they
created these statues of these planes
and they worshiped them and they and
they wanted them to come back yes
because they got food and you know all
kinds of F things from the planes like
they thought them as thought of them as
deities right the same way we would
think of something from somewhere else
yeah yeah so yeah that in my field has
been called the cargo cult the UFO cargo
cult right and um obviously Tyler and
James view these parts as as donate they
call it the donation site or right so
giving it the idea that is that just one
Theory yeah that's just one Theory other
theories that there's a biological
organism that encounters a lightning
storm and it actually crashes and
there's physical bodies oh yeah there is
that yeah there's that going what's your
take on that because that's one of the
things that grush talked about and some
of the other people talked about that
there there are biological things that
have been recovered well what impressed
me about the way about what he said was
that he used the term biologics and I
actually know that term because that's
the same term that Tyler was talking
about when he was creating materials in
anti-gravity spaces on on space shuttles
and such so I was wondering because
David grush does get his information
from people in allegedly in the programs
but he's never seen these materials that
I know of I think he has some firsthand
experience that he was not able to talk
about okay that he's alluding to okay I
think but this is a this is recent and
he's been very careful about how he
releases this information and what he's
able to release and not able to
release and that that I was like okay
yeah so I mean I've not seen any any
bodies nor have I seen intact craft but
I also have had now remember I don't
have a clearance like he has so I can
actually talk about what people have
told me I have had people tell me that
yes Diana there are intact craft I don't
know I mean maybe uh
so I don't know Joe have you um studied
Bob
Lazar okay yes I always asked about Bob
Lazar yeah and I don't know but I can
tell you that people that I've met who
are associated with the programs tell me
that he's he's he's right now I know his
backgrounds and I know you know all the
things I I don't I don't have an opinion
one way or the other but I can also say
that a lot a lot of times people with
very disturbing backgrounds you know who
could be easily discredited are given
information and shown things and told
things well I would think that that's
sort of like a little Escape Clause yeah
I think so I think it is I mean the
guy's obviously a genius and was
obviously a propulsion expert put a
[__] jet engine on a Honda in like
the 1980s he's a f fascinating guy yeah
and um you know he claims that there's
some element some element that exists
other in other places in the universe
which leads me to
believe well not even to believe but
like so here's the question are some of
these things from other planets is that
also in the equation I mean just because
something is traveling
interdimensionally we do know that there
are an infinite number of planets yeah
in the universe I mean we have no idea
how many of them are capable of
supporting humanlike life or some other
kind of life or a an infinite number of
varieties of life and if that life can
do what we've done and get to some part
of its progression where it's capable of
creating what we're calling artificial
intelligence or super advanced
technology why wouldn't it come here yes
I have I'm not dis I'm not discounting
ET so that could be there too I think so
especially because of the ways in which
the materials are being manufactured off
Planet like the ones that we just saw
you know that you know and that was
information when I met Tyler 2014 and
now it's a full-on thing that's
happening right so it's it's a
supercharged program of creating things
that will help us off Planet I mean
certainly then
yeah I think so I mean but I don't know
right so I have to just be honest so it
might be a bunch of different things
happening all at the same time
interdimensionally
extraterrestrial something from a
distant Galaxy that's figured out some
new method of propulsion that's beyond
our imagination that can visit and then
also things that are coming here from
other
dimensions yes and even recently
somebody had you know yeah well I can't
say any I can't say I'm sorry I don't
want to be that person that goes on your
show and says oh I can't I can't say
that but I
probably the most likely there are um
CRA if there's crash retrieval part you
know crash retrievals here on Earth
perhaps there are in space as
well do you when they talk about
inventions that emerged post Roswell
that's one of the uh points of
speculation is that we have back
engineered something and that this led
to the creation of fiber optics and a
lot of other technologies that seem to
emerge after that time yeah uh part so
this question was prominent in my mind
in 2012 when I met jacqu Val so I was
already aware of his work even as a not
a person who hadn't studied UFOs or even
believed in them jacqu Val is just one
of these people right that you come
across his work and he's fascinating
so I thought it was strange that Not
only was he a person who was you know
pre-engineered arpanet right he was on
arpanet which is pre- internet he was
creating that at the same time as being
obsessed with UFOs and doing you know
being a ethologist these things seemed
that they had to be together right
there's something that you know what's
going on here so um and I'm in touch
with him um often
and he says a lot of things that are
rather cryptic but sometimes I ask him
specifically was was what you were doing
on arpet related to back engineered UFO
parts and then he'd say something like
there are many secrets in Silicon Valley
or something like that yeah yeah he's
real cryptic he's kind of difficult to
have a conversation with
publicly you know well it does have a
lot I guess there are lots of secrets in
Silicon Valley of course which is where
he lives yeah um another thing that was
really fascinating about your book was
you were talking about how much religion
he studied yes yes that was really
interesting so in the book what I do is
I uncover not just him but Alan heck
they were friends and they were both
rosac crans which is a a form of he
might not like me to say this but it's a
form of mystical Christianity in a sense
but a lot of rossau crucians don't view
their Roots as Christian they they look
at it as Egyptian and but it's basically
it's an esoteric tradition and it
involves meditation I think it most
likely involves this thing that you and
I have been discussing in this the whole
talk so far is the pineal gland thing
you know the the access point because
both of them believe in this kind of
life this meditating and things like
that and so I included references
everything I say in my books by the way
I pass to the person that I'm writing
the chapter about so everything that I
said about jacqu I gave it to him
beforehand and I said are you okay with
me saying this publicly and so it passed
all the the tests um and I also talk
about going to his apartment and seeing
his um Library which is an amazing
Library um and he has Stained Glass from
chart uh Cathedral uh and chart
Cathedral is a special place for Rosa
crucians like a special place of
presence of the Sacred so and he
actually did those himself so he learned
how to do stained glass from people at
chartre by the way and yeah just amazing
and he had a lot of books on angels and
and fallen angels in that Library like
uh almost like it it was almost like
going into the Vatican archive going
into this place because these looked
like first editions or close so you know
really really old books about this topic
Fallen Angel yeah I was pretty shocked
when I had when I went I was we were
going to have lunch and talk about the
crash site and maybe talk about you know
what I learned from Tyler and that kind
of thing and we went to lunch and then
he said do you want to see the library
and I was like yes of course so I saw
the handwritten documents from Project
Blue Book um and that was just going
into the library that wasn't actually in
the library then when we got in there um
I noticed a big bookcases of these books
and of course I was drawn to them and he
said he picked out one and he opened it
and it was about angels and he said this
is the you know this is a book about
angels and I could see that and I was
looking I was wow and then I looked at
the other bookshelf and that bookshelf
was just as impressive and then it was
about fallen angels He said oh this
one's about fallen angels and then he
made a joke and he said you can't have
one without the other and I thought that
yeah I thought that was
interesting that does seem to align with
what we're talking about with like the
struggle of Good and Evil it does that's
what he said too and um and I was
actually shocked at that point I was
like wow so just you know be I'm a
professor of religion you know so I'm
like I'm right about you know my
intuition was somehow confirmed and by
the way I think people I think this
should be re I'm not sure if this is
totally true but I believe he was the
inspiration for the French character in
Close Encounters of the Third Kind I
think so yeah
yeah